begin here this morning with the
senate's own saturday session a rare one
to begin voting on a wide-ranging but
revised economic package that stands to
be a key piece of president biden's
administration
democrats are pushing forward on the 740
billion measure in the evenly divided
50-50 senate with all republicans
against it democrats say the bill which
is known as the inflation reduction act
tackles climate change expands health
care and lowers drug prices republicans
are strongly opposed and are promising
to slow down the voting procedures to
make the process difficult
natalie brand is on capitol hill with
the latest on this natalie good morning
good morning jeff there are still a few
key steps to go but democrats are
confident about what would be a big
victory for president biden's
legislative agenda around three months
ahead of midterm elections
this bill is a game changer for working
families in our economy the breakthrough
bill is expected to take a major step
forward today kicking off a weekend of
debate on the senate floor we're going
to keep working until we get the job
done senate majority leader chuck
schumer believes all democrats are now
on board after he struck a deal with the
final holdout arizona's kirsten cinema
on thursday and west virginia's joe
manchin last week nobody should expect
legislation of this magnitude to be easy
democrats argue their bill titled the
inflation reduction act will lower
health care prescription drug and energy
costs for americans
it would invest nearly 370 billion
dollars in climate programs and would
provide tax incentives to people who
invest in clean energy from their homes
to cars
the legislation aims to reduce emissions
by 40 percent by 2030. is that realistic
we think it is definitely realistic this
bill will do far more than any bill
that's ever been considered by congress
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions but
republicans argue the bill will make the
economic climate worse with tax
provisions including a 15 percent
minimum tax on large companies this is a
big tax increase on job creators in this
country that won't isn't going to do
anything to address the inflation crisis
in this country i'm hoping
that we can come up with
proposals that will make sense to a few
of them and they will abandon this jihad
their own to tax and spend
now while republicans firmly oppose this
bill senate democrats can pass it
without their support using a budget
tool known as reconciliation which
requires just a simple majority the
first test is expected later today with
an initial vote to kick off up to 20
hours of debate a final vote on this
bill could be as soon as early next week
michelle
all right natalie we'll see if they pull
the trigger thanks so much